я до того не 20 дідрик і а дзвоніть
здавалося газі ночі право ще прощаючи
прийшла одна чайна кузьмич як
професію
придумав дуже самі творчості дзвонив з
справними стати
[музика]
я прислухалася дцп і після 9 класу
прийшла почате стілець для чого лежав і рук
при частому сподіванні прийшла на практику на
теплоелектростанцій з початку було
складно вчора за тебе такого сили працею
до металу din правий по новачок
заплутувало калу наг шилась загс ями ваш
спеціаліст на най дівчинки проїзд іншого
місця такі купа так кар'єри можна
єдиний це
за rus хороші зварювати навагу золоту
шапку і було вухо не моя рука моя рука
це бузкові чапка b3 keep the запинок
носимося з правом даєте за 1 проти 1 вона
сиськи важливі об'єкти інфраструктури
адже лівий ікло нашу роботу закласти
душу багатий ми не важливі вироби частину
корейська і сибірська не завдання у 3 ми
то пак і гордість києву чого їм за
дикі моїй роботі сили місця моя світла
добру she все проти як треба